kevin gosselin is going to go to the
mound for the giants he's seven and one
on the season with a 143 era his first
loss
last time out against the nationals two
down for
escobar eduardo escobar switch hitter 15
home runs 45
batted in feels pretty hawaiian today in
the city
swinging a line drive to right coming in
yastremski to make the catch
out number three little top spin liner
diamondbacks go down in order a quiet
first inning which has not been the norm
here the last
couple of days for the d-backs offense
now we'll see what the giants can do
wade solano ustremski coming up
diamondbacks nothing
zach allen has been activated from the
injured list he will be on a pitch count
today
his last outing was in an extended
spring training game
he's donovan salado no score bottom of
the first
count is now full of salado the pitch
swinging a miss
96 mile an hour heater swung through
that's two outs
walker who is not having a great year we
have seen him in the past though
be a very dangerous hitter gaussman
with the one-two pitch and another
attempt to hold up and walker again just
could not do it strike three swinging on
the splitter
so here's casalli gallon this year had
made five starts before his injury
that ball is hammered deep left center
field
way back there goodbye
and there it is the first home run
as a giant for curt casalli
and that was a long one just to the left
of the 399 marker out there
which can be a graveyard for home run
hitters
two-nothing giants and this is a big at
bat right here infield's going to come
in
giants can add to their lead mauricio
dubon
comes up with the runner at third with
speed
the 1-0 is lined in a left-field base
hit
man he smoked a liner past the dive of
nick
ahmed duggar comes in to score
three-nothing giants
that's how you're supposed to do it
right there
three-nothing san francisco now here's
gossman
left to right in the outfield peralta
pavemen smith and josh reddick
squares early the 2-2 butted foul again
and gusman down on
strikes two outs and now here's salado
gallon set and the one two
swinging a fly ball to right down the
line
over his reddick and in foul ground
makes the catch
about five feet shy of the fence to end
the end
josh reddick for the diamondbacks here's
the pitch
swing and a miss by redick he chased a
splitter that wasn't even close
casale has to go pick it up and he'll
throw to first to complete the put out
but
kevin gausman gets his second strikeout
here is
josh rojas now cardinals are in
fourth place in the central now a swing
and a miss strike three he got him
with the splitter so gausman gives up
the hit to the pitcher the only base
runner the d-backs have had so far but
he gets
two more strikeouts wilmer flores
started that
three-run second in the rally with a
walk infield comes in
no outs wilmer flores waiting
2-2 pitch is hit to right center field
that should be plenty deep enough
reddick coming over
and he'll make the catch tagging from
third ustremski he'll come in to score
without a throw wilmer flores knocks in
a run with a sacrifice fly it's four
nothing
now here's belt brandon belt
seven for 12 in this series
pitch swing and a miss got him to chase
a change up down
here comes dubon one two pitch
swung on and drilled past third and
headed down the left field line
extra bases duggar coming to third and
wotus is waving him home
the ball is dug out right beneath the
foul pole by peralta
and duggar scores easily all the way
from first on that line shot double
by mauricio dubon five to nothing giants
now here's salad
for two walker way off the line at first
rojas position towards the middle
and second solano hits it on the ground
to third love by escobar throws
to first and the inning is over san
francisco tanks on a run on the rbi
double from duvall
we've played four san francisco five
d-backs nothing
that would give kirk casalli in at bat
in this fifth inning giants ahead
five-nothing stephen duggar on deck
to sally he's had four hits in this
series
swing the knee it's a high drive into
right center field
that's the big part of the yard and the
wind starts to carry it and nobody
catches it
smith the center fielder redick the
right fielder they came close together
and neither one of them caught it
scoring his belt all the way from first
and going to third is casalli
and he beats the relay a triple
six to nothing giants he never had a
triple
now here's dubon he has two hits set
the one two swinging a pop-up
on the infield right side the second
baseman rojas fighting the sun a bit
makes the catch
and the inning is over san francisco
adds another run
on the miss play triple we've played
five so now riley smith will bat
riley smith over as a hitter with eight
strikeouts
now he swings and misses at a splitter
strike three
now here's christian walker let's see if
christian can pick up a couple of rbis
here
here's the 1-1 christian chops one to
short
charging is dubois bobbles can't get the
handle everybody
safe a run scores and the d-max are on
the board they trail six to one
oh there's a break and now here's david
peralta here comes the 3-1
swinging a ground ball base hit back
through the middle
escobar around third he will come to the
plate the throw is cut off
rbi single david peralta and it's a six
to two ball game
that'll bring up ahmed going to
guzman throws ahmed hits one to left
center field duggar on the move duggars
gonna get there and make the catch
that's the third out and kevin gausman
limits the damage
nice job there diamondbacks get two and
up comes
kurt casalli who's having his best day
at the plate
as a giant 02.
sally rips one into left field that's
another hit for casalli
flores is going to get the ghost sign
david peralta's throw here it comes
flores slides
and he's safe seven to two giants
the big game continues for curt casalli
here is duggar he's had a triple a
single and a walk
in that order duggar blasts one down the
right field line
this one is going to drop on the warning
track a fair ball
and kick into the corner and then it
rolls away from reddick casalli coming
around
third and he will score into second
duggar with a double eight to two giants
dubon
a single and a double he's knocked in a
pair in his three trips
smith's first pitch broken bat roller
back to the mound backhanded by smith
slings to first
in time to get to bond and the inning is
over but
two two out hits in san francisco a pair
of runs we've played seven
san francisco eight d-max two haven
smith comes up
smith got the rally started last inning
with a base hit he comes up for the
fourth time
one for three and he swings at the first
pitch pops it up
center field duggar comes in we can see
his sunglasses glistening that's a
bright sun out there but he makes the
catch anyway and gausman
retires his side in order and does so
very quickly
so kevin gausman's going to get a
standing ovation as he walks off the
field from the fans around the giants
dugout
he's pitched great again today and who
knows maybe that will be it for him
yestrepski has gone one for three
with a double he's also been hit by
pitch and he's hit the ball hard
so he continues to swing the bad well
here's the 2-0 yes rips this one into
right center field another hit for him
that's going to score two runs vossler's
in
solano right behind him he'll score
yostremski knocks in two
ten to two giants as long as christian
walker
reached out an error his last trip
knocked in a run
1-1 christian taps it back towards the
middle behind the bank at second solano
has it slings to first
to the out as escobar scores an rbi
fielder's choice
for walker and it's a 10-3 game
david peralta will come up as the last
chance for the d-backs
here's the pitch peralta on the ground
to the hole at short over to backhanded
duban he kind of stumbles
and then shows off his strong arm he
fires to first in time to get peralta
and the game is over the diamondbacks
have set an all-time
record they've lost 23
consecutive road games never before
in the history of major league baseball
has that happened for any team